Star Wars fans have a lot to look forward
to, as the franchise's universe is going to
get a whole lot bigger in the next few years.
Aside from a new trilogy and spinoff movies,
there's no telling how many animated or live-action
TV shows are coming.
But fans might not even realize that there
are chapters in the Star Wars saga they've
missed completely - chapters that shouldn't
slip by unnoticed, for the best possible reasons.
Here are Screen Rant's Amazing Star Wars Spin-Offs
You've Never Seen.
The Star Wars Holiday Special
When Star Wars proved to be a massive hit,
CBS came up with a plan to bring that success
to the small screen, pitching George Lucas
on a holiday variety show.
The director agreed, but only if the story
centered on Chewbacca's Wookie family: his
father, Itchy, his wife, Malla, and his son,
Lumpy.
Aside from some small cameos from the movie's
cast, the special was a random mix of unrelated
skits that disappointed almost everyone who
watched it.
It was aired just once, before George Lucas
could buy all master copies of what would
come to be known as "the worst two hours of
television ever" by TV critics.
The worst part?
The short cartoon that introduced bounty hunter
Boba Fett was so good, it left fans wondering
why a full series wasn't greenlit to do what
the variety show failed at.
Caravan of Courage: An Ewok Adventure
Three years after the first Death Star was
blown to pieces, while Luke, Leia and Han
were helping the Rebels gain an edge, an entirely
different adventure was taking place on the
forest moon of Endor.
The made-for-TV movie follows Mace and Cindel,
a brother and sister stranded on the planet,
who team up with the Ewoks to rescue their
parents from a strange monster.
After the embarrassment of the Holiday Special,
George Lucas crafted the story himself, with
the art director of the original films, Joe
Johnston, overseeing the production design.
The result was an award-winning adventure
celebrated for its special effects, and the
start of a new franchise within the series.
Ewoks: The Battle For Endor
The made-for-TV sequel to the first Ewok Adventure
follows an older Cindel, who is soon orphaned
and tossed into the forest with the Ewok hero
Wicket, to find an old hermit who will help
them save the moon from invaders.
The movie was, once again, overseen by Industrial
Light and Magic’s creative leads, and the
story crafted with the help of George Lucas
directly.
The movie gave Wicket even more attention
after his well-received appearance in Return
of the Jedi, and earned the studio even more
acclaim for pioneering a new form of camera
work on a relatively small budget.
Star Wars: Droids
George Lucas's second trilogy may have told
the origin story of Anakin Skywalker, but
it wasn't the first prequel series to fill
in the events of the galaxy far, far away,
happening before the original series began.
Set in the period between the rise of the
Empire and A New Hope, the animated series
follows C-3PO and R2-D2 in one adventure after
another, as the pair of droids always seem
to have a knack for getting into trouble.
The cartoon included appearances from fan-favorite
characters like Boba Fett, IG-88, and too
many space pirates, smugglers and gangsters
to count.
With Anthony Daniels still supplying the voice
of the cartoon 3PO, and the prequel trilogy
referencing the cartoon years later, it's
a serious part of the series canon.
Star Wars: Ewoks
Droids are fine for a few laughs, but the
miniature, walking, talking teddy bears in
Return of the Jedi were a cartoon creator's
dream - and the main reasons that the animated
Ewoks got almost three times as many episodes
as the saga's star droids.
With the cartoon set years before the events
of the TV movies, the first season of Ewoks
was surprisingly high quality, and enjoyed
by kids and their parents.
The second and third seasons' writing and
story lines instead aimed squarely at younger
viewers, but boasted some talented writers,
including Paul Dini, years before he's create
the animated Batman and Superman cartoon.
The Ewoks series also offers a major twist:
since the cartoon characters all speak Basic
English, we assume George Lucas was revealing
that the Ewoks were only pretending not to
understand the Star Wars heroes.
And we thought they were friendly.
Star Wars: Clone Wars
To be clear, that's "Clone Wars," not "The
Clone Wars."
Before the CG TV series became a reality,
this hand-animated cartoon followed the saga's
star Jedi between Episodes 2 and 3.
Establishing why General Grievous was a villain
to be feared, the series of short episodes
- drawn by the same artist as Dexter's Lab
and Samurai Jack - showed the Jedi Knights
using their Force powers in the ways fans
always hoped to see.
The short series is often overlooked in favor
of the lore-heavy computer-animated show,
but it shouldn't be: it includes some of the
best moments in the entire Star Wars story.
Those are the key spin-off stories of the
Star Wars saga that most modern fans may have
missed, and are still worth visiting today
- for a variety of reasons.
Which are you favorite extensions of the main
Star Wars series?
Let us know in the comments, and don't forget
to subscribe to our channel for more videos
like this one!